[Musica]
e l'idea per questo talk mi è venuta
leggendo una stanza tutta per sé di
virginia woolf e scorrendo mi sono
imbattuta in questa sua riflessione
c'era un'enorme quantità di opinioni
maschili a confermare che
intellettualmente non ci si poteva
aspettare niente dalle donne ci sarebbe
sempre stata questa affermazione non può
andare questo sei incapace di fare
questo da contestare da annientare
probabilmente per una scrittrice questo
germe non ha più tanta efficacia perché
ci sono state scrittrici di grande
merito ma per le pittrici deve avere
ancora una certa forza e per le
musiciste immagino è ancora estremamente
attivo e velenoso però questo lo
scriveva nel 28 però chiaramente dalle
suffragette degli inizi del novecento al
2022 cioè di passi avanti ne abbiamo
fatte abbiamo tre donne ai vertici
dell'unione europea sempre più donne e
ceo e membri del board e in tutto il
mondo c'è ma di un ramo c se la musica
classica rimane indietro e per
dimostrarvelo andiamo a vedere come la
situazione nelle orchestre più
importanti con sede in europa
prendiamo il top del top
i berliner philharmoniker ovvero
l'orchestra con sede a berlino
prendiamo uno strumento a caso che ne so
il clarinetto bene allora vedete da zero
donne che erano prima adesso sono
vero ok va bene però questa è
un'eccezione perché chiaramente tra
decine di strumenti o sono andata a
prendere l'eccezione va bene non fa
niente cambiamo tromba romba benissimo
ottimo
davvero che erano prima da esso sono
vero
con i fiati non abbiamo molta fortuna
cambiavo sezione va bene le percussioni
le percussioni chadaj tutti da bambini
ci siamo messi a tamburellare con le
pentole di casa ma vuoi che non ci siano
delle donne andiamo a vedere percussioni
zero
ma sapete che vi dico io direi che in
germania ci siamo rimasti abbastanza
andiamo in austria dai wiener
philharmoniker riproviamo daccapo ok
0 percussioni va bene andiamo avanti
vero
clarinetti ora visto visto ve l'avevo
detto è le cose sono cambiate no
adesso invece prendiamo uno degli
strumenti proprio più classici in
assoluto e cambiamo paese
prendiamo l'orchestra del consorzio di
amsterdam ai doniamo che tre violini c'è
una percentuale altissima femminile
vediamo addirittura che le donne sono 70
per cento degli uomini il restante 30
con un dato così incoraggiante allora
andiamo a vedere quante donne ricoprono
il ruolo di spalla dell'orchestra che
praticamente è il ruolo più importante
dopo il direttore
beh io signori direi che a questo punto
ci possiamo consolare con la direzione
d'orchestra
ecco guardate ecco seguendo sempre
usando sempre i colori blu e rosa che a
me personalmente non piacciono qui sono
riportate tutte le stagioni operistiche
dei più importanti teatri di tutta
europa e noi la vedete va bene facciamo
uno zoom
ecco quelle piccole montagnette che
vedete rosa rappresentano le direttrici
d'orchestra che sono state chiamate a
salire sul podio dei teatri
come vedete la situazione si presenta da
sola è drammatica e io posso
semplicemente dire che nella musica
classica così come in tanti altri
settori ci siamo ancora lì sulla
diligenza di ombre rosse e vorrei dire
tra l'altro che la stazione di partenza
nei film si chiama pure tonto e ho detto
tutto
e per quanto riguarda la composizione
torniamo alla nostra virginia woolf che
poco più avanti scrive
la donna che compone musica si trova
nella posizione in cui si trovava
l'attrice al tempo di shakespeare
aprendo un libro sulla musica in
quest'anno di grazia 1928 a proposito
delle donne che cercano di scrivere
musica troviamo queste parole
una donna che compone è come un cane che
cammina sulle zampe posteriori non lo fa
bene ma vi sorprende comunque vederlo
quanto accurata la storia del ripetersi
anche in questo caso la situazione per
le compositrici si presenta da sola se
infatti vi chiedessi in questo momento
di nominarmi un compositore voi avreste
il palazzo della scelta da mozart
beethoven chopin ciajkovskij chi più ne
ha più ne metta se invece vi chiedessi
di nominarmi una donna
difficilmente chi non ha familiarità con
la musica classica riuscirebbe pensare a
clara dic
fanny mendelssohn oppure ancora
cementerie vere ma non c'è da stupirsi
perché di fatto le donne sono state
sempre scoraggiate dall'intraprendere la
carriera musicale
pensiamo infatti per esempio a fanny
mendelssohn sorella di uno dei più
importanti compositori di tutta la
storia della musica felix mendelssohn e
se non lo conoscete sappiate
semplicemente che probabilmente vi siete
sposati o vi sposerete con la sua marcia
nuziale
panni mandelson ha scritto centinaia di
composizioni e se ve ne fosse stata
sempre incoraggiata dal fratello e il
padre l'aveva sempre ostacolata perché
riteneva che la musica per una donna
dovesse essere semplicemente un
ornamento e nulla di più
si tratta di un'ennesima dimostrazione
del pensiero della rita levi montalcini
il capitale cerebrale dell'uomo e della
donna e lo stesso in un caso è stato
incoraggiato nell'altro storicamente
represso
non ha avuto certamente una vita più
semplice nemmeno clara dic
pianista importantissima dell'ottocento
e che tra l'altro ha suonato con
importantissimi musicisti dell'epoca
come per esempio list e tra l'altro è
stata anche la moglie di un celeberrimo
compositore robert schumann ma udite
udite
all'epoca lui veniva sempre presentato
come il marito di lei perché è bene se
all'epoca era lei ad avere molta più
fame rispetto a lui infatti a
viaggiavano insieme e quando
incontravano marito dice male il marito
di carica ma che cosa fa nella vita io
compongo e poi ha scritto alle
composizioni che oggi conosciamo
celeberrime clara dic è una donna che
oggi noi definiremmo
multitasking allora per farvi capire
pianista concertista acclamata da tutti
che si esibisce nelle sale più
importanti viaggia per tutta europa in
un'epoca in cui certamente non c'erano
le business class moglie di un marito
geniale ma che poi finisce manicomio
madre di otto figli
ebbene sì e in tutto questo pur e
compositrice pensate che a 14 anni ha
scritto un concerto per pianoforte e
orchestra
eppure anche lei in età adulta ha avuto
dei dubbi
una volta pensavo di avere un talento
artistico ma ho rinunciato a questa idea
una donna non deve desiderare ricomporre
poiché nessuna si è dimostrata capace di
farlo dovrei aspettarmi di essere la
prima
clara ma se per questo quante cose non
sapevamo fare noi donne votare prima
delle leggi entrare in politica
laurearsi dirigerli azienda e la lista
si allunga
però questo per farvi capire come anche
una donna come lei dalla sua genialità
dal suo successo abbia dovuto affrontare
il fardello del pregiudizio
eppure lei ha composto per che ci ha
lasciato delle bellissime composizioni
come il caso di questo notturno
[Musica]
a
no
[Musica]
la
[Applauso]
come dicevano un cane che cammina sulle
zampe posteriori
e vorrei tra l'atro dire che questo
brano l'ha scritto a soli 16 anni
ora a noi non interessa e non ci deve
interessare in alcun modo un mondo
diviso in due perché esattamente quello
che abbiamo avuto per troppo tempo e
questi sono stati risultati però capite
anche voi che nel 2022 i numeri non
possono essere ancora questi è
francamente io vi devo confessare che
sono stanca che le donne debbano sempre
adattarsi al mondo e credo che sia
arrivato il momento che il mondo si
debba adattare alle donne grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]